let's see if we can use what we know
about Springs now to to get a little
intuition about how the spring moves
over time and hopefully we'll learn a
little bit about a harmonic motion we'll
actually even step into the world of
differential equations a little bit and
don't get daunted when we get there or
just close your eyes when it happens
anyway so I've drawn a spring like I've
done in the last couple of videos and
zero this this point in the x-axis
that's where the the Springs natural
resting state is and in this example I
have a mass of mass M attached to the
spring and I've stretched the string
I've essentially pulled it so the mass
is now sitting at point a so what's
going to happen to this well as we know
the the force the rest rative force of
the spring the rest rate of force of the
spring is equal to minus some constant
times the x position the x position
starting at a so initially the spring is
going to pull back this way right the
springs are going to pull back this way
it's going to get faster and faster and
faster and faster and we learned that at
this point has a lot of potential energy
at this point when it kind of gets back
to trusting state we'll have a lot of a
lot of have a lot of velocity and a lot
of kinetic energy but very little
potential energy but then its momentum
is going to keep it going and it's going
to compress the spring all the way until
all of that all of that kinetic energy
is turned back into potential energy
then the process will start over again
so let's see if we can just get an
intuition for what X will look like as a
function of time so our goal is to
figure out X of T X as a function of
time that's going to be our goal on this
video and probably the next few so let's
let's just get an intuition for what's
what's happening here so let me try to
graph X as a function of time so time is
the independent variable and I'll start
at time is equal to zero so this is the
time axis and let me draw the x axis
this might be a little unusual for you
for me to draw the x axis in the
vertical but that's because x is the
dependent variable in this situation so
that's the x axis very unusually or we
could say X of T just you know this is
you know X is a function of time
X of T and this state that I've drawn
here this this is what at time equals
zero right so this is at zero let me
switch colors at time equals zero what
is the x position of the mass well the x
position is a right so if I draw this
this is a actually let me draw a line
there now I might come in useful this is
a and then this is going to be let me
try try to make it relatively that is
negative a that's minus a so at time T
equals zero where it where is it well
it's at a so this is where the graph is
right now let's actually let's do
something interesting let's say let's
define the period so the period I'll do
with a capital T let's say the period is
how long it takes for this mass to go
from this position it's going to
accelerate accelerate accelerate
accelerate be really going really fast
at this point all kinetic energy and
then start slowing down slowing down
slowing down slowing down and then do
that whole process all the way back
let's say T is the amount of time it
takes to do that whole process right so
at time zero today and then we also know
that at time T at time T this is time T
it'll also be a day right we're just I'm
just trying to graph some points that I
know of this function and just see if I
can get some intuition of what this what
this function might be analytically so
if it takes T seconds to go there and
back it takes T over two seconds to get
here right the same amount of time it
takes to get here was also the same
amount of time it takes to get back so
at T over 2 at T over 2 what's going to
be the x position well T over 2 the the
block is going to be here it will have
compressed all the way over here so T
over 2 it'll have been here and then at
the points in between it will be at this
at x equals 0 right I'll be there
and there hopefully that makes sense so
now we know these points but let's think
about what the actual function looks
like will it just be a straight line
down than a straight line up and then
the straight line down and then a
straight line up that would imply if
think about it if you have a straight
line down that whole time that means
that you would have a constant rate of
change of of your x value or another way
of thinking about that is that you would
have a constant velocity right well do
we have a constant velocity this entire
time well no we know that at this point
right here you have a very high velocity
right you have a very high velocity we
know at this point you have a very low
velocity so you're you're accelerating
this entire time and you're actually the
more you think about it you're actually
accelerating well you're actually
accelerating at a at a decreasing rate
but you're accelerating the entire time
and then you're accelerating and then
you're decelerating this entire time so
your actual rate of change of X is not
constant so you wouldn't have a zigzag
pattern right and it'll keep going here
and then you'll have a point here so
what's happening when you start off
you're going very slow your change of X
is very slow and then you start
accelerating and then once you get to
this point right here you start
decelerating you start decelerating
until at this point your velocity is
almost your velocity is exactly zero so
your rate of change or your slope is
going to be zero and then you're going
to start accelerating back your
velocities going to get faster faster
faster it's going to be really fast at
this point and then you'll start
decelerating at that point so at this
point what is this point corresponds to
you're back at a so at this point your
velocity is now zero again so the rate
of change of X is zero and now you're
going to start accelerating your slope
increases increases increases this is
the point of highest kinetic energy
right here then your velocity starts
slowing down and notice here your slope
at these points is zero so that means
you have no kinetic energy at those
points and just keeps on going on and on
and on and on and on so what does this
look like well I haven't proven it to
you but but out of all the functions
that I have in my repertoire this this
looks an awful lot like a trick
metric function and if I had to pick one
I would pick cosine Y because cosine
when cosine of zero I'll write it down
here cosine of zero is equal to one
right so when T equals zero this
function is equal to a so this function
probably looks something like a cosine
of and I'll just use the variable Omega
T probably looks something like that
this function and we'll learn in a
second that it looks exactly like that
but I want to prove it to you so don't
just take my word for it so let's just
figure out how we can figure out what w
is and it's probably a function of the
mass of this object and and also
probably a function of the spring
constant but I'm not sure so let's see
what we can figure out well now I am
about to embark into a little bit of
into a little bit of calculus actually a
decent bit of calculus and we'll
actually even touch on differential
equations this might be the first
differential equation you see in your
life so it's a it's a momentous occasion
but let's just move forward close your
eyes if you don't wanna be confused or
go watch the the calculus videos
especially the at least so you know what
a derivative is so let's write this
seemingly simple equation or let's
rewrite it in ways that we know so
what's another way what what's the
definition of force force is mass times
acceleration right so we can rewrite
Hookes law as let me switch colors okay
I choose which colors mass times
acceleration is equal to minus the
spring constant times the position right
and I'll actually write the position as
a function of T just so you remember
we're so used to X being the independent
variable that if I didn't write that
function of T it might get confusing
you're like oh I thought X's is the
independent variable no we're actually
going to do it because in this and this
function that we want to figure out we
want to know what happens as a function
of time so actually this is also maybe a
good review of parametric equations this
is where we get into calculus what is
acceleration
what is acceleration if I have if I call
my position X
my position is equal to X as a function
of T right I put in some time and it
tells me what my x value is that's my
position
what's my velocity well my velocity is
the derivative of this right my velocity
at any given point is going to be the
derivative of this function the rate of
change of this function with respect to
T so I would take the rate of change
with respect to T X of T and I could
write that as you know DX DT and then
what's acceleration
well acceleration is just the rate of
change of velocity right so it would be
taking the derivative of this or another
way of viewing it it's like taking the
second derivative of the position
function right so in this situation
acceleration is equal to we could write
it as there's you know I'm just showing
you all the different notations X prime
prime of T second derivative of T of X
with respect to T or these are just
notational d squared X over DT squared
so that's the second grade oh it looks
like I'm running out of time so I'll see
you in the next video remember what I
just wrote